yeah which is fine because there's no
good Nation but also at the same time
it's like if you don't tell us this
we'll believe something way [__]
worse yep I just can't wait for the
Super Bowl
[Music]
though welcome back everybody to a very
very satisfactory video of the careful
boys which is totally an notr it's off
the Record okay regards what you want
and we're going to talk about something
a little bit pressing in the in the
nation today we're going to talk about
them illegal immigrants situation
crossing the border into America and how
we feel about it wait OTR style or
article style o said that like twice can
you guys stop so it's funny because like
I always get reminded to myself that
like as much as we hate it and it's like
you know there's a lot of negatives that
come from it if Philippines shared that
border with Texas they'd be jumping that
[__]
too I'm okay a lot of people would and
then I would feel completely different
so it's like hard to say you know I'm
getting hella content right now that
tells me like why it's bad why we don't
want it whatever right but I'm not
hearing the counter of why we should let
people in why it's okay why we can
support like I don't I don't understand
um what the argument is for allowing it
well it's on the Statute of Liberty dude
you got to give me all your weary all
your weary travel and [__] which is
probably more manageable when it was a
couple hundred thousand versus Millions
I'll tell you the most common argument
okay what is it they'll say well this is
stolen land
anyway yeah it was stolen like ages ago
but they've created rules and laws and
now it's like there's a system that
people have to follow now so I talked to
someone that's a certified stamped
double confirmed
uh left believer and he sent me a bunch
of and he sent me a bunch of Articles
and what he said is um it's because
illegal immigrants pay their taxes more
than legal immigrants so when you bring
these people in they actually help fund
the way the government needs to operate
illegal that pay taxes that's what I I
was like that's [__] [__] and
that's that's like um you know when um I
don't know any illegal immigrant that
filed for taxes exactly I actually know
illegal immigrants from Asia and you
know Mexico and a lot of I mean maybe if
they're saying like if they get fake
papers and then they get their paycheck
right then it's paid okay payroll tax or
whatever uh uh uh not payroll tax uh
income tax fine that that makes sense
but if you're a contractor if you own a
business everything is done in cash and
there is no reporting so I was like what
the [__] but that's what he said is
their biggest argu they always say is
the funniest thing too they always go
they was go they pay taxes more than
Americans do and I'm like first of all
why why you got to [__] on us but how's
that even possible like statistically
right if there's 300 thou like 300
million US citizens that's like written
in like when they do the census yes
there's five people in this house right
like and if there's only like less than
10 million immigrants even though that's
a big like number I'm probably
overshooting how many illegal immigrants
there are how is that even numerically
even possible yeah even if it's true
like I almost want just want to say who
gives a [__] because it's like if you
want to be here you have to come here
legally that's always been the deal
that's the weirdest thing to me that so
I always zoom out of this argument and I
just go back to like if you want to be
here you have to do it like you have to
follow the law if I and people always do
this thing where they're like yeah but
if you know you we're tearing them away
from their families and [__] like that
I'm like dude if I commit a crime guess
what happens I don't get to see my wife
I go to [__] jail that's what happens
yeah the weirdest part to me is like the
logic part right I'm like so this person
is coming into the country and they like
like lift up the [__] border and you
walk through then I'm like then don't
put me through TSA like when I come back
in why am I a citizen I'm getting
punished I have to go through customs I
have to wait in line why do they have to
check my bags like doesn't make any
[__] sense like this guy it's like
come on in this have to go through TSA
who this guy could have a [__]
grenade in his butthole and [__] and I'm
getting [__] hassles for my creatine
I'm like what the [__] and they got in
New York right now they're giving visas
um to these illegals who are coming in
right so you're getting money you're
like a Visa card Oh you mean you mean
like a credit card a debit card yeah
prepaid credit card exactly and and and
I'm like what about like a homeless
veteran like and to me it's not like e
either or it's just why can't we
prioritize the people who are here who
like did things who were were like who
are citizens so what I so I guess like
this is kind of fresh in my memory
because um Hannah had to recently do
everything legally to get her uh
permanent residency in the states right
so I was thinking about this and I was
like well when people follow the law
you're telling those people that you're
actually now getting punished for
following the law because if people can
walk in and work immediately Hannah was
like I want to start working on projects
I want to start doing all these things
but you technically cannot work unless
you have a Visa here
so if other people are allowed to do it
illegally and they're not getting uh
punished they're actually punishing
those who follow the law and then she's
like I want a side income I want to do
this or whatever but if it's illegal
then I'm not going to even bother
because it could jeopardize my um
ability to get a citizenship right so
what about all the people who's playing
by the rules they they're actually being
punished for following it my buddy's
stuck in the UK right now because of his
Visa he's got a Visa issue it's the same
[__] yeah and why doesn't he just go to
Mexico and walk right across if they're
not even going to kick him out and like
you know and to me look it's [__] like
the situation is [__] as far as like
trying to get a visa and all that stuff
it's all [__] it sucks it takes
forever like I wish all that was much
smoother but we all know that government
doesn't do things very well yeah and
that's why it's it's like a part of me
is's like a hater in the sense that I've
had throughout my life so many family
and friends pay a lot of money to
hopefully get in and then they either
get scammed it amounts to nothing they
still get rejected uh they have lifetime
banss because they overstayed when they
were working here and then went back
still and it's like a part of me is a
hater we like damn it's so easy for
these guys to just walk in you know yeah
they don't even have to get interrogated
they don't have to do all the stressful
things that people who follow the rules
have to do and then yeah when it comes
to Asia they're like no sorry only your
best and brightest please right it's
like [__] I do I do feel a little bit
like uh maybe it's just me but like you
know like when you were in in school or
in class or something like that and it's
like people like cheating on an exam if
you like studied for it it's like I
never got mad at the person who was
cheating you always are just kind of
like what's up with the [__] system
or the teacher you know what I'm saying
yeah yeah right right like the the
people who illegal immigrants illegal
immigrant why' you cross cuz if
I would do the same [__] are you mad at
that one guy though that's like you
don't know who I am but you will find
out who I am that [__] was gay it
[__] found out who he was and it's
like holy [__] this guy yeah isn't he
doesn't he have links to terrorist
groups and stuff and he's like a
hardcore at first I just thought he was
like going to go make a name for himself
and rock and roll that's what I thought
too I thought he was trying to be like a
rapper I was like on his side yeah I was
like good for you that was [__]
gangster when he said that I was like
one day you will see me with like chain
you're not smart enough to know who I am
like [__] dude this guy's Batman has to
come after him but even like that
article we just did where there's the
the guy that came and doesn't speak the
language I'm like when you do have
people that come that don't know the
language the Customs or whatever it is
going to wreak havoc on our current
infrastructure the misunderstandings
like even if someone drives on a
different side of the road and then they
come here and they don't know it's just
a lot of things that like I think
there's a reason why there's a process
where you have to come in and you kind
of get acclimated to a certain you know
like a way of living and if you have
people and we've seen all the footage
from the borders it's like from every
single country you could think of and
then now you have like all these people
come in like how is our
hospitals or even restaurants you know
how are we going to be able to support
such a huge influx in population it's
just what I don't understand is like we
actually have a really good integration
system it's been proven right all of us
are kind of like proof of that um an
example is Vietnamese refugees right hey
when there were several different um
integration camps in the states where
you get process there you get
interviewed and then a lot of uh the
churches worked in in in hand in hand
with the government and they would
sponsor different families but in the
camp while you were waiting for your
process to find a family get sponsored
by or whatever they would teach you
skills they would teach you like you
know doing different types of jobs or
whatever so when you're ready to
transfer out you can immediately be a
part of the system work go to school
they would have English classes and all
that stuff so I'm like why can't we have
that like if we're going to let people
in why can't we have a system where they
first go into like a a education program
or whatever and it's like all right
we're going to teach you about America
this is how it works cuz they had the
that they had that in every single like
recent Refugee thing and step one that
was legal still too yeah that was legal
that was yeah like our we're getting off
right off the wrong foot already it's
just like it's weird to hear someone go
we need to make illegal immigration
legal it's like what the [__] weird
sentence not to brag I'm a world
traveler been all over the [__] world
nowhere I haven't been but when I'm
there they always want to know the same
thing who are you and what are you doing
here like they want to know what you're
doing that's why you should say you're
not smart enough to know who I am you
will know and they're like
denied you know like yeah he's weird
denied denied and that happens I had
knowbody who got denied cuz he he was um
they had him on some kind of list or
whatever so he had to turn around and
fly back home I mean like I I I to me I
think most people just want a job right
they just want to earn and but in every
group that comes over there are also
people who are running away from
persecution whether it be from crimes
committed in their own country or
whatever you know so how do you filter
that out cuz even when it was legal like
let's say when Cubans I mean this is the
story of the good Tony Montana right
like like and there's every example of
an immigrant group group coming in and
then so does their organized crime so
like how even when it was filtered even
if it was like done legally it still
falls through the crack so now if it's
illegal it's like that's that's even
crazier and it goes both ways like
people commit crimes here and run to
Mexico hell yeah dude so it's like you
need to check both sides both way it
shouldn't be easy either way and a lot
of times too not to get too woke on your
asses but these people get exploited by
our system too like you know paid under
the table paid low wages but in their
country that's considered amazing wages
so they're like [__] it I don't care
that's why I'm for illegal immigration
we're sweat shopping basically oh for
sure I could pay somebody $3 an hour and
then every single time they complain or
want to go to the bathroom I'll just be
like I'll send I'll send you back to
I'll send you back I'll call the I'll
call it's like what happens to Parolees
too like you got pares who are working a
job and they're like hey dude you kick
back some funds to me uh or else I'll
call your [__] brawl officer you know
what I mean but that's that's the funny
that's the funny double standard that we
have where like that's looked at as
Charity when you hire like an illegal
immigrant to like work in your kitchen
but then if you're like buying she in
it's like oh you sweat shop supporter
right you know it's like okay I get it
it's like but we're also still
domestically doing that [__] right well
we're Hypocrites as [__] yeah so how do
you guys feel about the current
situation with like Texas and that's the
part that's extra weird it's crazy
hilarious why is there an argument on
the other side of that because if if the
if they want to secure the Border I
thought that was common sense I also
think that we have case studies right
like all the states that are like we're
a sanctuary State come on like the the
next month we can't [__] handle this
[__] [__] anymore stop this [__]
that's what New York started saying
those Super Cuts are hilarious when you
see like the mayor being like you're
welcome you come here come here and then
she's like we can't thank you she's like
like he's like we simply do not have the
resources yeah and I'm like how come
those [__] you guys should have
been jumping in yeah guest Texas help
secure the Border but like I don't know
what the real reasoning is KL Harris
during the campaign Trail being like
come on in you it's all good and then
after she gets in the vice president
she's like don't come did you seen that
bit yeah yep don't come well what the do
you guys what do you think of the Matt
mat oh it's not Matt Kim's Theory but he
did share it how like bringing in all
these illegal immigrants and then
finally allowing them to vote will be a
way to keep Dems in power I I mean yeah
they're losing their voter base over
Years first gen immigrants are usually
Democratic voters unless they come from
communist countries they they're hella
they go super conservative real quick
yeah my parents like regardless of where
they're at with like who's running for
whatever they're always going to vote
Republican and I remember asking I was
like why it's like because the
Republicans that we were able to come
into this country so no matter what it's
like loyalty they're always going to be
like dude and I was like wa that that's
a whole another level that like is
actually beyond what I even think so
then on the demp side that sentiment
yeah could be I just know that we
probably hate immigrants so sucks but so
what's this what's the state right now
the state is Texas is saying [__] you to
Washington DC yeah
we have our own National Guard and then
what is Biden's move Biden then that
that National Guard follows the
governor's for the context right so like
Texas put a barb wire basically
protecting their border right sealing
their border then the feds come in and
cut the razor wire and they're like no
we we're opening it back up and Texas is
like why the [__] are you doing this I'm
we're going to send the National Guard
to the Border plus it's an election year
so now all of a sudden Texas is doing
[__] you got to love that part too um
but yeah then now here we are and other
states are now sending their National
Guard to bet Tex Texas's national guard
as a [__] and in the federal
government's like argument is well you
guys are stopping us from doing our job
you're in the way that's their Prime
argument basically they're like the
razor like when they you know how they
have those press conference sounds like
when cops run into FBI yeah well they're
saying it interferes with our ability to
yeah and then they're like at what way
though exactly they're just like you're
not doing their jobs that's why what job
are you doing and on top of that how
does this obstruct your way and they're
like oh the agents can't get in because
of the razor wire they can't get into
the area and they're like at what area
and they can't explain it so that's
their argument of let us in open it up
there's no Cogen argument nothing the
top so weird there's an agenda clearly
that we're not being told and I think
okay so like there's the surface battle
that we're that we're seeing right the
legalities and all that but I believe
that like there's always ulterior
motives to why things are IL logical
yeah like the real Roi what is that
taking out all the emotion from this
entire situation like what's the logical
side of it yeah and I think we kind of
touched on this yesterday but um in I I
I think with the US and the Western
Nations no longer having manufacturing
and a lot of poverty we don't have grunt
work we need like in order for this
system to work we need fresh new
immigrants and cheap labor um I don't
think our Administration is that
selfless in thinking no it's not so much
no no no no let finish my point so let
me finish my point okay
so we need a lot of field and um people
working in in construction and all that
right how is this group going to be
replenished every year and then I make I
I I've seen this observation happening
in the in Europe right like in Western
Nations when you make money people don't
want to do those jobs anymore cuz you're
living good you push your kids to become
college educated and become a part of
the corporate class right and so what
ends up happening there's a huge deficit
of a group that needs to keep the oils
like turning right and also there's the
birth rate issue so when you have those
two things happening how do you quickly
remedy the situation and that's why when
mer was the leader of the UN she was the
one that opened up the floodgates for
the refugees to come cuz I was like why
are they letting so many in it it can't
just be white guilt there's no point to
that right and then it's because Europe
was the first to have that issue with
the population problem that they need to
replenish so all Western nations are
having a birth rate problem population
problem and that sustains the economy
and I think that's the main reason why
that they have to do this this or else
it's it's that uh what do you call it
that upside down pyramid of of but isn't
it also supply and demand thing where
you know we talked about HVAC people
recently right like shout out to those
guys um yeah but those guys they pick if
they want to work or not they make like
[__] 200k a year um because there's
no one doing the [__] jobs like you
said so it's a supply and demand thing
so now more people are like maybe I'll
do HVAC you can [__] pave your own
way and like set your own hours and like
just you can do whatever you want so I
think those construction jobs you would
You' see ra wages raised if we did have
control over our immigration situation
is what I hear argued quite often like
maybe people who are going to University
or whatever they're like [__] this I I
don't know if I love this I'll go be a
construction worker because it's paying
40 an hour or whatever because they the
wages would would increase as demand and
that thought process that still comes
from a person that I think cares where I
don't know if Biden cares like I think
it makes way more sense wait I have
investments in Ukraine they're get
they're in a fight I need to go protect
my assets you know so like the person
that thinks like that it's hard for me
to go oh wait this guy really cares
about the next generation of America it
still feels like very selfless no it's
it's still protecting assets because you
need so humans are the cattle you need
to replenish your stock or else you're
going to lose money for the for your but
it's like five degrees of separation you
mean like generationally different so
it's not immediate yeah like Ukraine
it's like Biden LLC is literally in
Ukraine
theying my direct asset and I think like
the the way at least that we've been see
how politicians move or even like you
know like the Pelosi and whatever it's
like it's a direct benefit I'm only
going to protect things that are
directly beneficial to me and so even
needing cattle it seems like 6° or 10°
of Separation where they receive the
benefit so I don't so I don't see the
ROI like it's not this cabinet I think
that's why people are mad I don't think
it's actually Biden or politicians call
when I see these type of moves I see
like it's long game yeah there's so like
military and all these things right it's
not immediate it's long game so they
have to play long game so if you don't
have a country that's sustaining the
next 10 to 20 years then you're kind of
screwed like it's kind of like how
Biden's it might be CIA like objective
it might be someone else saying I don't
see it as like a like I don't think
Biden's even going to survive you know
the next five years or whatever but then
there's there's corporate families that
will be in power 100 years from now that
are thinking it's like so how do you I
just think people are angry right now
because we never we don't we have a
crony capitalist system obviously but
but what if what if we just like did a
couple of basic things right like like
actually control the border so maybe
people wouldn't have to compete with
people who are getting paid under the
table for jobs like you could actually
see wages increase for once in our
[__] lives right like I just think
that if like just basic level of [__]
that that like just cover these bases
and let's see what happens like give
give the system a shot but you can't do
that when you thumb your thumb in the
scale the whole time that's how people
feel I think I really do feel like we're
not we haven't yet seen the end of the
academic bubble where all these people
are going to college for useless degrees
I think we haven't seen the end of that
yet so I do see the need for people to
do these jobs cuz I don't think we're
going to have enough of those you've
seen a lot of millennial journalists get
fired but even even
if blue
but just population in general right
like like like if Korea is a clear kind
of example of a country that doesn't
allow any immigrants and they're talking
about as as as early as in 30 years
they're not going to have a population
that's the the future here if they don't
I guess when they weigh out the two of
of do you bring in immigrants or not or
do you just let the let the country kind
of die off and also I think the argument
too is it's not really immigrant or not
or like immigration or not immigration
it's actually there's three of them it's
not immigration legal immigration and
illegal immigration cuz people that are
have a population decline they're not
just going come in yeah right you know I
think everyone's for immigration but how
can we do it in the safest way possible
but is it that they can't do it fast
enough that's what I'm saying so like
cuz if they actually brought out if they
brought out the rates right the of
immigration is too slow because of
process then like let's troubleshoot the
process so that the people that come in
don't affect the current citizens I see
versus like we're like the argue point
is here but then like what's the real
[__] like over here that so I think the
real [__] is the thing that can't be
debated legally I think that we we need
illegal immigration to operate in
America that's that was the point okay
so that's the thing that no one can
admit basically that's that's that's
what I mean by like we that it's never
been legal we've been yeah operating on
uh low wage and just like before then
the thing that the people feel on the
ground level is what the states are
mandating for like whether it's a
sanctuary state or a state that like
believes that they need to protect their
borders because they can't handle it
with the resources right so everything
isn't this cuz nobody's capable of
making this zoomed out Grand macro
decision for the greater good nobody's
responsible for that and they
generationally won't even be alive by
the time it actually affects him but
they just need to park themselves in a
St that aligns with where they feel cuz
like we're sitting in California where
now people from are escaping New York
and coming over here cuz they're going
to get [__] health benefits and [__]
like that kids since 2015 and and people
50 years and over now all illegal
immigrants are getting [__] tax paid
subsidized health benefits over here but
then when that goes too far then they go
somewhere else yeah us California is
going to be [__] we can't do that you
know what I mean I understand the how I
get it now but the funny thing is I look
at it like a pasta strainer where it's
like yeah there's going to be some good
hardworking awesome people that get here
illegally cool but what happens to the
people that are scum and now they just
stayed in your
town yeah and yeah I don't think Texas
wants to be that [__] place that's it
they're just like we know what's
happening and this is going to get
sifted through and we're going to get
the leftovers well also how about the
nice people out there who work like four
[__] jobs they can barely keep up
they can't even pay their their bills
and they're behind in everything and
they just see oh well these people get
come here and they get free healthcare
and like meanwhile I have hospital bills
stacked all the [__] way up why do
you think people are mad also if you
don't tell people what the [__] is going
on from the top down of course they're
going to come up with conspiracy
theories about what's going on because
how do you backfill this like lack of
information you have hundreds of
thousands of people literally videos of
people coming here and then they walk
right up to border patrol get on a bus
and we don't even know where they go we
have people in airports all the time i'
I've heard directly from people who were
like yeah I was at in airport and there
was a bunch of migrants who were there
and they were all given passports they
were all are given tickets and then they
were all given money and then they I we
don't know where they go like so of
course people are going to backfill it
with conspiracy cuz you're not telling
us what the [__] going on but that's
the thing like now that you say that I
didn't think about how like they just
can't they just can't say that's another
part of it like I'm going to use these
guys so then people start saying
Invasion right they start kicking around
that like they're all they're all
military aged men they're all going to
be a sleeper Soul yeah and then there's
just a racial uh what is it called
undertone under yeah for sure there's
like an animosity that doesn't need to
be there like an extra hate but you're
making you're making new hate because
like I said the people who are behind
are seeing them get benefits why not me
if only the people up top could go no no
no it's fine we are nefarious and we
need this very we're very very evil yeah
cuz you're making you're making the
citizens hate the immigrants yeah
exactly yeah and then you're also
stressing out your own infrastructure
like no you don't get it like if you
want to eat strawberries some Guam
malons have to get tased by by cops you
know and you're like what the [__] it's
the same reason why a Hawaiian person
would hate that they flew homeless
people to [__] white you know like
you'll just hate those guys yeah but
then they didn't you know that wasn't
their choice they just were like they
got pushed they're like oh whatever
national security issue is scary though
yeah especially with like everyone
hungry you know with bricks and like
just like everyone is on the move to the
top and then when you're when you don't
lock your front door it's like what the
[__] it's pretty scary to think that you
have someone that's like literally I
have nothing to lose I have everything
to gain now and if desperation hits to a
point and you have something that they
yeah if no one can explain to us why
this is a good idea as letting just a
ton of people in unchecked then
obviously we're going to go well why is
this Chinese company buying this farm
and why are all these undocumented
people working there is this a military
base on our soil and then I'm like that
kind of sounds more realistic than yeah
right whatever the government's telling
us cuz that just sounds crazy they're
giv nothing and you know even what we I
think you we talked about this before
about like the food plants that are
getting like like all of a sudden like
arson at Food plants all over the
[__] place in America right cattle
just [__] burning up yeah so people
start connecting all these dots on a day
where three guys were working in a
[__] gigantic ass multi-acre and then
they recently found the lab uh a a
disease lab here from some Chinese spies
and [__] remember
yeah what it was like ran by a fugitive
yeah yeah yeah there's a lot of [__] we
have our own Wuhan here Isn't that cool
but that that's what's funny is that
when you ask the government like why are
you doing this and they just go like I
can't tell you yeah that's what sucks
but I want to but you're not ready trust
us you're going to love the answer we
can't also we can't pay attention for
very if they're only that good-hearted
too I know I know it's like it's like if
they told me like what the real motives
were I'd be actually believe it yeah
which is fine because there's no good
but also at the same time it's like if
you don't tell us this we'll believe
something way [__] worse yep I just
can't wait for the Super Bowl
though
hey